you've traveled over 500 million years
into the past to experience some of the
most dangerous seas and alien organisms
ever to exist on Earth welcome to the
Cambrian
Period what would Earth look like
compared to how it does now what could
you eat to
survive and what kind of creatures would
you need to watch out for
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived in the Cambrian
Period traveling 500 million years into
the past well the first thing you should
probably do is get your bearings
unfortunately for you the Earth you knew
so well is gone or rather it's yet to
come into existence you'd find yourself
on a planet with shallow Seas covering
most of its surface and and in the
southern hemisphere where you're
standing right now the supercontinent
rodinia is just starting to break apart
there's gondwana the land mass that will
go on to include South America Africa
and Australia lorentia which includes
most of North America plus Siberia and
baltia which span across what you might
recognize as the eventual Scandinavia
Eastern Europe and parts of Russia you
wouldn't really recognize anything
though no familiar mountain peaks or
Lush Greenery it would mostly be Barren
except for mosses and algae spread
across the landscape but as you made
your way over to the Ocean's Edge you'd
soon discover an explosion of Life
thriving on this early Earth but be
careful some of it could kill you just
below the ocean's surface you'd be
treated to a glimpse of a time when life
on Earth was diversifying faster than
ever
before there were some pretty wild
creatures during this time but
unfortunately they've gone extinct I
don't know about you but I personally
don't want that to happen again with the
creatures we have today luckily I have a
solution from our friends over at Planet
wild they're doing some amazing work
attempting to bring back endangered
species and best of all you can take
part in their missions stick around to
the end of the video for more
information and a free gift you've
arrived right in the middle of the
Cambrian explosion this relatively short
stretch of time between 530 and 540
million years ago saw a boom of new
organisms scuttling across the seafloor
you'd find alien looking Critters that
at first sight might scare you right out
of the water but don't worry they won't
harm you these are
trilobites ancient creatures that
scavenged around from tropical shallows
to icy waters near the poles with their
spiny Limbs and wide circular mouths you
could watch them search for a buffet of
worms and algae to feed on at this point
you'd start to notice that breathing is
a little more difficult on Earth than it
is in our day and age that's because the
atmosphere's oxygen levels are
significantly lower than what you're
used to even down at sea level it would
feel like you were at a much higher
altitude and since the ozone layer has
yet to fully develop you'd also have to
do your best to Shield yourself from the
much stronger UV rays pounding down on
you from the Sun I hope you brought some
sunscreen because you won't find any
here for a long long time by now you'd
be getting hungry especially after
watching those trilo bites Munch down on
all their yummy snacks and you'd start
to wonder what on Earth you'd be able to
eat in the Cambrian
Period well your best bet would be to
stick close to the sea but be careful
don't reach for those worms too quickly
some of the food sources you'd find
could be highly toxic you'd be consuming
strange new bacterias that your body
isn't used to so brace yourself for an
upset stomach or something even
worse and while you're out hunting for
dinner will keep an eye out for larger
Predators lurking in the shadows but
don't worry too much a lot of what
you'll see are organisms like the
anomalocaridids these shrimp-like
animals could grow up to 38 CM so they
wouldn't do you much harm you'd actually
be the apex predator at the top of the
prehistoric food chain as your days
stuck in the Cambrian Period turn into
weeks you'll continue to struggle with
adapting to your new environment
environment the low oxygen levels would
make even the simplest physical tasks
more difficult and without fruits
veggies and your usual proteins you
could be headed toward
malnutrition now despite all the
challenges you'd be witnessing one of
the most significant eras of life's
development on this planet all those
creatures in the sea will go on to
evolve and be the foundation for much of
Life as We Know It now when your time
machine one day kicks back into action
you'd be happy to leave this ancient
period behind but maybe you're not ready
to go back home just yet I wonder what
the devonian period was like well that's
a story for another what
if hey don't click off just yet as a
thank you for making it to the end of
the video I want to give you something
our friends at Planet wild are going
going on monthly missions to preserve
nature and Wildlife while documenting
all their process on YouTube their
latest involves planting over 40,000
trees in Sagal it's all funded by a
community that wants to give Back To
Nature by funding ecosystem restoration
missions where it really matters by
being a member of the planet Wild app
you also get to vote on how you'd like
your funds to be used I've been
subscribed to it for a while now and I
like how I can track their progress and
find videos documenting their missions
in fact I love the app so much that I
want you to try it out for free that's
why the first 200 people that sign up
will get the first month on me just
click on the link in the description or
scan the QR code and use the Creator
code what
[Music]
if